PREMIERE PARTY PLANNERS.
AND SHE HAS BIG HOPES OF TAKING
HER COMPANY,
VERONIQUE EVENTS,
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
- MY WISH IS TO BE
A BIGGER COMPANY
WITH A LOT OF ARTISTIC DIRECTORS
AND, YOU KNOW, A WHOLE CREW.
- BUT TO DO THIS, SHE'S GOING
TO NEED SOMETHING
THAT MAKES HER DIFFERENT
THAN EVERYONE ELSE.
SO I PAID VERONIQUE A VISIT
TO SEE IF I COULD HELP.
HEY.
[dog yips]
OH, JEEZ--
WHEN SOMEONE'S HAVING A PARTY
THE BIGGEST STRESS COMES
FROM WHO TO INVITE.
- ABSOLUTELY.
- I MEAN, SOMETIMES
THERE ARE JUST PEOPLE
YOU DON'T WANT TO INVITE.
- YES.
- BUT YOU DON'T WANT THEM
TO KNOW YOU DIDN'T INVITE THEM
BECAUSE THEN THEY'LL HATE YOU.
BUT YOU DON'T WANT THEM TO KNOW
THAT YOU DON'T LIKE THEM.
RIGHT?
- YEAH. BUT THE THING IS,
YOU HAVE TO MAKE CHOICES.
- BUT MAYBE YOU DON'T.
THESE DAYS, MOST PARTY
INVITATIONS ARE SENT
AS A DIGITAL INVITE
THROUGH EMAIL.
SO IF IT WAS POSSIBLE TO DEVELOP
A TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD SEND
CERTAIN PEOPLE'S INVITES
DIRECTLY TO THEIR SPAM FOLDER,
VERONIQUE'S CLIENTS COULD INVITE
EVERYONE THEY KNOW TO A PARTY,
WHILE GUARANTEEING THEIR
UNDESIRED GUEST WON'T SHOW UP.
AND IF CONFRONTED AFTER
THE EVENT BY THAT GUEST,
THEY COULD SIMPLY SAY,
"I DID INVITE YOU.
DID YOU CHECK YOUR SPAM?"
- THAT IS A GA--
GREAT TRICK.
- I MEAN, AS THE ONLY PARTY
PLANNER TO PROVIDE THIS SERVICE,
YOU WOULD GET EVERYONE WANTING
YOU TO PLAN THEIR PARTY.
- YOU KNOW,
I WANT TO SEE HOW IT WORKS.
I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE THIS INFORMATION.
AND THEN IF I HAVE THE USE, YES.
WHY NOT USING IT?
- BEFORE VERONIQUE COULD OFFER
THIS SERVICE TO HER CLIENTS,
I'D FIRST NEED TO CREATE
THE TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE IT WORK.
SO I HIRED A SOFTWARE ENGINEER
NAMED CHRIS,
WHO BUILT ME A CUSTOM INVITATION
SYSTEM TO EXECUTE MY IDEA.
- ALL RIGHT, SO THIS IS
THE INVITATION FORM.
- RIGHT.
- AND THEN ON THIS SIDE
YOU ENTER THE EMAILS
WITH YOUR DESIRED GUESTS
AND YOUR UNDESIRED GUESTS.
- SO THE EMAILS IN HERE
GO WHERE?
- THE DESIRED GUESTS EMAILS
WILL BE SENT TO THE INBOX.
BUT WITH THE UNDESIRED GUESTS
I JUST PUT A WHOLE BUNCH
OF SPAM WORDS IN THAT EMAIL,
SENT IT THROUGH A FOREIGN SERVER
THAT WAS LOCATED IN RUSSIA.
- SO THAT MAKES IT GO TO SPAM--
- YEAH.
SO THAT MAKES IT GO TO SPAM.
- AND WHAT WORDS DID YOU USE?
- UM, I USED "VIAGRA", "PENIS",
"PENIS ENLARGEMENTS",
I PUT EVERYTHING FROM
1-INCH PENIS ALL THE WAY
TO 10-INCH PENIS.
- WHY 1-INCH PENIS?
- UH, BECAUSE IT'S JUST MORE
TO PUT IN THERE.
- 'CAUSE I'VE SEEN SPAM
FOR LIKE, 8-INCH PENIS,
9--
- YEAH.
- BUT I'VE NEVER SEEN SOMEONE--
A SPAM EMAIL SAY, LIKE,
"DO YOU WANT A 1-INCH PENIS?"
- [laughs]
- BUT YEAH.
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU DID
A GOOD JOB.
- YEAH.
- CHRIS SENT A TEST INVITE
TO MY EMAIL
AND IT SEEMED TO WORK GREAT
WITH THE HIDDEN KEYWORDS
DIRECTING IT
STRAIGHT TO MY SPAM FOLDER.
THERE IT IS.
SO THE NEXT DAY, I RETURNED
TO VERONIQUE TO SHOW HER
WHAT I HAD DEVELOPED.
[dog yips shrilly]
OH!
OH, SORRY, SORRY.
JESUS CHRIST.
THE PROGRAM WILL ADD HIDDEN
WORDS TO THOSE EMAILS
THAT WILL MAKE THEM GO
DIRECTLY TO SPAM.
- OH.
- THERE'S "PENIS", "ROLEX"--
- I MEAN THE IDEA IS--
- UH, "PENIS ENLARGEMENT"...
- OH.
- "VIAGRA", "8-INCH PENIS",
"9-INCH PENIS",
"10-INCH PENIS",
"11-INCH PENIS"...
- GOOD.
- "VIAGRA PENIS"--
- I MEAN, I DON'T NEED TO KNOW
EXACTLY--
IS IT IMPORTANT FOR ME TO KNOW
THIS INFORMATION?
- IF ANY OF YOUR CLIENTS ASK,
YOU SHOULD KNOW.
- NO,
NOBODY WOULD BE INTERESTED.
- WELL, SOME PEOPLE
MIGHT WANT TO KNOW HOW IT WORKS.
IT'S INTERESTING SCIENCE.
VERONIQUE WAS IMPRESSED.
BUT IN ORDER TO SHOW HER
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT
MY SYSTEM WOULD HAVE,
I DECIDED TO THROW
A SMALL PARTY AT MY PLACE
AND PUT SOMEONE THAT I KNOW
ON THE UNDESIRED GUEST LIST.
FOR THIS, I CHOSE SALOMON,
WHO WORKS ON MY SHOW,
BECAUSE I KNEW IT
WOULD HURT HIS FEELINGS
IF HE FOUND OUT
HE WASN'T INVITED.
SO AFTER SENDING THE INVITES,
I HEADED HOME TO PREPARE
FOR MY PARTY.